hey guys welcome back to the second
video in my recap series
of the dubai rapid tournament
uh if you saw the first video i won a
pretty smooth game with the mexican
defense
in this game we're gonna see round two
where i played against a player by the
name of laxman rated 1462
and either way pieces
and i'll admit before the game i was a
little bit conflicted what opening to
play
just because there were so many
chess fans coming up to me
making a lot of comments that they
they've enjoyed my london lectures
and
because i've kind of developed this
reputation
of
specializing in the london opening
i didn't really want to play the london
uh at least in this game
and i decided to play
a different opening that i still
have a lot of experience in as an
english opening not too many people know
this but this has been in my main
tournament repertoire
for the last many many years
and i learned this when i was rated
around like the low 2000s
and i've played this on and off for
probably last like five or six years and
one of the reasons to play the english
especially against a lower player is a
lot of people are are prepared for e4
and d4
and may not have as much experience
in
english opening lines
um my opponent played e5 so we're we're
not transposing into any like queen's
pawn and basically we get what we can
call a reverse sicilian
after knight c3
knight f6 it's basically like i'm
playing a sicilian but up a tempo so
there's some uh different nuances to be
aware of
and here the main move is pawn g3
which we can see is most popular in the
leachat database
but in the masters database
and the move that i like to play
is knight f3 and this is a more
confrontational move i immediately
attack the pawn
preventing black from playing the media
d5
and
one of the points of this move is it's
trying to induce black to play e4
which would in some sense be a mistake
because after knight g5
the pawn is overextended and in a
variation like
d5 cd5 bishop f5 there's going to be
enough resources for white to uh to win
the pawn and actually i'm realizing
right here that white can immediately
take
after all the trades there's queen a4 in
the end
so
black has to be a bit careful in these
lines
um one thing i will say
and this is something that uh
actually i i saw earlier today anna
crowling was doing a stream
with her dad
who's a well-known grandmaster
and there's a variation here pawn b5
uh known as a ballon gambit her dad's
name is actually isbellin so it's named
after him
and it was super cool lecture i think
she's planning to put the video on
youtube
but uh this is a tricky sideline which
if white's not prepared for it can be
very dangerous i studied this a long
time ago and i would have known to play
the um
basically the so-called refutation d3
i don't want to go too far down the
rabbit hole but um
it is fun sometimes to to study these
these off-beat
and sharp variations
so after knight three my opponent didn't
play e4
played by far the most common move
knight c6
and
here i played a move which has kind of
been a pet line of mine
over the many years
actually if we look in the database
the move i played is the fourth most
popular move
more popular is g3 e3 e4
but my choice is pawn a3
and the reason why i like this move
especially against lesser experienced
players
is
it prevents the bishop from developing
so actively
and there's a few potential traps here
like if the bishop does develop to c5
white can start with e3
and the media thread is to play b4 and
try and trap the bishop so if black is
really not careful this could
potentially happen
but i've had a decent number of games
over the years once in a tournament
probably a few times online
where my opponents play a5
and this allows for a center fork trick
after knight takes e5 i take c5 and d4
and i'm actually curious here
um i've had this position a few times on
each s
and uh the one tournament game i had
here my opponent played bishop d6 and
then c5 is very strong
and white already has a
very significant advantage
engine approved
so
black does have to be careful developing
the bishop too early
and i prevented bishop to b4 so it's a
bit of a question
how black should complete development
and my opponent played
one of the most natural moves pawn d5
now this move is a little bit risky to
play
because it's going into an open sicilian
down a tempo
and because i have the extra tempo
there's more room to play aggressively
which we're going to see
very soon how the game unfolds and how
black falls under major pressure
i will say the safer approach is to play
g6
and this is a more kind of slow
positional game
i would have played g3 bishop g7 bishop
d2
castling include d3
and play a structure like this which is
way more of a kind of standard english
position
but uh in the game my opponent played d5
and
we got
what we can kind of call a reverse
taimanov i'm not sure if lee chest has a
name for this
calls it king's english variation four
knights korchnoid line and the reason
for playing queen c2 it's a very
flexible move in some cases i want to
target the knight in combination with
pawn e3 and bishop e5 which we're going
to see
and i also control this diagonal which
could be relevant in in some cases
for example there's a line
bishop to e7 pawn e3
castling and then after takes takes
really nice move bishop d3
and in the masters database this has
been played good number of times
white trends not only bishop takes h7
but also bishop e4
in combination with b4 bishop b2 there's
a lot of ways to pressure black center
from very early on
so in the game
my opponent played very natural move
bishop e6
and one of the issues for black in this
sort of position is
natural moves
tend to fall into trouble very quickly
because after e3
bishop e7
i pounce with bishop to b5
and now we can see that black already
has a lot of issues to deal with
mainly the fact that the pawn is
undefended
and there's a lot of pressure against
black setup and it's not entirely clear
how to keep everything defended
a move like f6 which does defend the
pawn walks into d4 and white's just
continuing to throw punches here if pawn
takes d4 then knight can take back the
bishops hit knights hits
bishop d7 fails for knight d5
so we can see how things go downhill for
black very quickly so after bishop to b5
my opponent played bishop f6
which
looks like a natural move it's one
attempt to try and keep things defended
but here i go for 94
and okay this is where i'll hide the
notation don't want to spoil the rest of
the game
but knight e4 it's a nice multi-purpose
move
not only unleashing the queen
and mounting even more pressure against
the pin knight but also having ideas of
knight to c5
so in the event of queen d7
trying to keep everything defended
this just fails miserably to knight c5
queens attacked if the queen moves back
there's some nice tactics here knight
takes b7
queen takes takes and it's a fork skewer
of goodness and uh likes winning a ton
of material
so
my opponent took a bit of a think after
a knight e4
and realized that there's not a great
way to defend the knights
although maybe it should have been uh
like a move like 97 should have been
considered
but my opponent decided to castle
which i think in some sense is a decent
practical decision
uh trying to treat this as a gambit
and uh
baiting me to take a pawn and hoping for
some compensation
now i did go ahead i took on on c6 went
up a pawn
and now it's really up to black to try
and fight back in this position
so my opponent played rookie 8
and i castled
and right after i castled i realized
that i missed my opponent's next move
which my opponent played
relatively quickly is bishop to g4
and if i had seen this coming maybe i
would have played something different
like maybe h3 would be worth it
but the thing after bishop g4 is
black wants to damage my king side
structure
and there's not a convenient way of
defending the knights or moving the
knights
so
this is where i probably took my longest
think of the game
uh just trying to figure out how to deal
with
this potential threat
and i came to the conclusion that i'd be
okay with the transformation of the
structure
because there's not an easy way for
black to exploit the king
and i decided to play pawn to b4
now i do want to address the move knight
takes f6 which looks very natural i
think a lot of a lot of people watching
would play this move
but this only helps black because after
knight takes
there's potential for pawn e4
and rookie six is coming and it's a
little bit uh
murkier in in this position
so pawn b4 it's an attempt to complete
development
i realize my bishop it's my worst place
piece i wanted to turn it into something
useful
and uh i did allow bishop takes off
three g takes f3
and now rook to e6
so
there's still a little bit of uh of
concern given black has initiative
there's a potential of the rook lift
but after queen to c2 it still takes
time for black to try and organize an
attack so my opponent played bishop h4
one of only ways to make way for the
rook
and here i play knight g3
a very safe move
covering the g file
unleashing the queen along the diagonal
opponent pins and knight
and now i play queen e4 so centralizing
the queen
um
here i'm beginning to find some nice
harmony with the pieces the queen is
very useful in e4
pressuring a lot of targets in black's
position
my bishop is ready to develop rook is
ready to come in on top of all of this
i'm up a pawn and my king is very safe
and perhaps because of like all these
reasons that
the game is beginning to clearly go in
my favor
my opponent made a terrible wonder here
played the move queen d7 completely
missing that the bishop is now no longer
defended
i happily scooped up the bishop
i'm sure my opponent would have loved to
have a few extra moves to play this and
this and this and this
but just not enough time
i took on each four
rook h6 was played
i slide over would be very happy with a
queen trade
my opponent
continued the downward spiral
played queen g6
and allowed a very feel-good fork on f5
hitting the queen the rook and
threatening mate
so essentially a triple fork
and here's where uh black resigned
now black could try and defend with a
move like queen g6 or rook g6 but
ever which way black tries i'm gonna be
up a rook in the end
and a pawn so
not much hope left
so nine to five was a nice way of
finishing up my second round game
and this gave me a two out of two start
to the tournament
and if we reflect on this game it was
just a matter of getting an opening
where my opponent was perhaps a bit less
familiar
a bit less comfortable
didn't quite know how to deal with the
early pressure
uh which can be very typical uh from the
english opening
sometimes english has a reputation of
being more slow and maneuvering
but in a more open position like this
especially reverse open sicilian we can
see that black does have to be very
careful
and
maybe it would be worth my opponent
exploring some of the theoretical lines
a better option is to play bishop e7
and castle quickly
before
uh entering the the trouble lines with
the pin against the knight so uh i was
feeling pretty good this uh
set me up pretty well for round three
which i will cover in the next video
so hope you guys enjoyed the game
as always if you have questions leave
them below
i will be reading the comments
if you're enjoying the the series so far
feel free to like and subscribe
it does help the channel grow
and i'll see you in the next video